guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live version of the
minimalists podcast
and i want to invite you to join us for
a night of less find your nearest city
at the minimalists comm / tour we'll see
you there
America how do you ensure your clothes
last longer I wear the same clothes that
I love but they need to be replaced
quicker especially shoes so that was the
thing about the challenge right about a
project 333 is like you lose people at
the shoes right and so Eric is asking
how do I make my clothes last longer and
here's one my minimal Maxim is I'm
recycling our most popular one here love
people use things because she said I
wear the same clothes that I love and
and and I want to discourage you from
loving your clothes and I want you to
enjoy your clothes I want you to use
your clothes I want you to feel good
about the clothes that you're wearing
when we love the clothes I think
sometimes what happens and we need more
words for love anyway Yeah right
she doesn't mean that she like
heartthrobs over her clothes and her
clothes burn up she would have a funeral
for them and cry it's it's it's just a
word that we kind of throw out there and
not really thinking about the problem is
with the language we use also has a
weight to it right and so I I try to
save that that were in fact that we've
got Ella saying you know I don't love my
toys I love mom
and so like trying to use the more
appropriate language so saying I enjoy
my clothes or I use my clothes that's
one way to maybe untether from from that
feeling you have but Kourtney she she
says yeah I want quality clothes but I
feel like I always have to replace my
clothes what do you say I say do laundry
better yes so people ask me about
laundry a lot like I'm really surprised
I think my next book is gonna be all
about laundry because it always comes up
within the context of the challenge and
hold your socks better than I'm supposed
to fold my wait you have socks so I
don't do any more or less laundry than I
did pre prod
3:33 however I do laundry better so I
wash all my clothes in cold water and I
line dry almost everything so that's
what I recommend I think it'll really
help in terms of your clothes lasting
longer just don't put them through the
dryer and and if you do put them in the
dryer use like a wool dryer ball yeah
those are oh yeah they're great and
fabric softeners so bad for your
everything shouldn't be in your house
yeah with detergents like yeah wrong
detergents they have all the chemicals
they'll destroy your clothes there are
some great affordable eco-friendly
detergents I don't know the names of any
and now a word from our sponsor just
kidding so yes that's how to make your
clothes last longer and otherwise think
about it like this when your clothes
didn't wear out you had all it's because
you had so many backups so it's not like
replacing something is worse than owning
twelve versions of it right right and
that's the thing I'd rather have one
high quality pair of pants than ten
crappy pairs of pants that I mean that
does me that's worse for the environment
it's also worse for my psyche and for my
closet and from my home and everything
else right and so having the appropriate
amount doesn't mean you're gonna have to
never replace you're not gonna buy
thirty three out of their clothing and
say well I'm set for life no I'm set for
a season now it doesn't mean a literal
season but whatever that season of your
life is but occasion you got to replace
some things I have my shoes resoled from
time to time but eventually I have to
have those replaced even and it's okay
it's not about consuming nothing it's
about consuming less because you're
consuming more intentionally yeah and
when you're wearing like the same like
my jeans for example they will wear out
within and well if before I was started
getting Mission workshop which this is
not sponsored by Mission workshop they
just have really good high quality jeans
but before that I was one of my jeans
out probably once every six or seven
months I never want I never walk do I
never wash them well you know it's funny
Josh him and I will like purchase the
same exact lake
phone or you know like our laptops that
we got however many years ago like we
get it at the same time and my stuff
will always break and wear out first
Josh has very kindly lovingly pointed
out to me I'm very rough on my things
because I you know I'm not yeah I don't
care about how they look or animal
little yeah yeah I'm very enthusiastic
with my things but what I'll say though
is in might then this leads into my pit
the answer which is air on this air on
the side of quality not trendy so when I
go to purchase clothing I am looking for
a high quality product and like for
example my t-shirts again not a sponsor
but they're from son of a tailor and
they do really awesome work like you
they literally give you shirt that fits
you great you send them measurements
they'll send you a couple shirts you try
them on if it looks good you order some
more and they're a little bit more
expensive per t-shirt but like I've had
these t-shirts really going on three
years now and like they have I mean
they're starting to fade a little bit
but but three years old whereas before I
would get like an American Apparel
because it was it did look good on me an
American Apparel like at some point was
like you know cool and trendy but they
would wear out really really an American
Apparel shirt right now and that's
that's actually a really important thing
to highlight wouldn't you say Courtney
like what works for Ryan may not work
for me may not work for you and vice
versa right and so it's not about what's
appropriate for someone else and then
applying that to our life it's figuring
out what's appropriate for you
you